is you're
value added as you see it
that you are able
to
one
take greater risks
and two
find these gaps so you are
in a sense not
investing in what other
what is actually already happening
wherever it's happening but that you're
seeking out
spaces that you can have an impact and
leave a mark are those two things
operating at the same time
yeah so i think that
and it's interesting this is always a
debate that i have with myself of you
know wanting to be a leader and leave a
mark but then also something that i
think that people don't do enough of is
be a good joiner like there should be
awards for best middle management you
know like
and because there are and and i think a
lot of
areas suffer from too many people and
you touched on this a little bit before
too many people starting things
instead of kind of um
trying to to join or strengthen the
whole community and so
so we do with the foundation both so we
like this program we've developed but
with partners so we're not we're not
going to start a micro finance
institution that do this we'll partner
with one that already does
um and then there are some grants that
we make that are honestly writing a
check to a great organization so that
they can continue to do their work and
you know we say send us your report and
we'll see you in a year you know so i
think i think it's important to do both
you know to to
develop
develop a program particularly in issue
areas that you really care about so
efficient models for education
and then if it's something that's
wonderful like
you know parkinson's disease research
i cannot add to that into that field at
all except with treasure
and so
yeah you just look at it i think case by
case